let's stay in Texas a little bit and go
to Rick from Southeast Texas Rick from
Southeast Texas what just it's a Texas
sort of day you know Rick
Rick welcome
Rick you have self-muted you can unmute
yourself and then you'll be able to talk
to me
good boy
Rick you there buddy
can you hear me yes I can
hey sorry about that David hey so um I
really wanted to call in about something
more more meta perhaps the origins
oranges of your show um so I've been I
was wondering you know with with your
show you I mean you're a one-man show
and respectfully you that's that's where
you should be but have you ever thought
about
um like other channels incorporating
other people into your show not saying
you should but it's never a thought or
or you know something like that I really
want to see your your program you know
explode and and uh grow so what are your
thoughts on that yeah I mean listen
every program is different and sometimes
people will write to me and they'll say
you know David your program would be
better if you had an ensemble cast where
you had a whole bunch of people behind a
desk or whatever you know your show
would be better if you didn't take calls
or if it was all calls or if you did no
interviews or all interviews the thing
about it is every show is where it is
because of the way that it has been
produced and I am always very skeptical
of saying if I make this show more like
another show it will do better because
maybe that's not the way this show is
supposed to be so the way we produce the
show it sort of makes the most sense the
way we're doing it right now and and the
way that I do the sort of Ensemble thing
is I'll appear on other shows like next
month I'll be on the Patrick Bet David
show down in Florida or might be in
Florida actually I forget where they
film and I've got some other appearances
coming up
um so that's the way I sample different
formats rather than like changing what
we do it's by appearing on other shows
that kind of do it differently if that
makes sense
absolutely you know I agree and I think
that's what makes her feel a little bit
more more specialized is you know you
kind of really get to know you and and
we hope that um we get to see more from
you soon I'm I'm a flada Florida
whatever you say transplant so I really
hope you enjoy the sun down there David
I'm looking forward to hopefully good
weather absolutely
of course thank you so much have a
wonderful day all right there is Rick
from Southeast Texas very very powerful
declaration and questions all of which
we love